the other night I was watching the
fugitive which is one of my favorite oh
yeah and I always forget that you're in
the future yes and I was a local hire
yeah yeah yeah we were in Chicago and it
was it was it's it's nice because it
felt like you you got that gig yeah
iconic movie you have a scene with
Harrison Ford or do he's he was a great
guy too in fact he gave me some really
good advice there was a close-up on me
when he's leaving you know I play he's
on the lam and I knew him before and I
say I'm going to protect you and he says
you know you just stay where you ne
leaves and I'm supposed to have this
longing and my mouth is wide open
I've never worked on camera before I
don't we done know nobody knew who I was
and you came over to me says I have a
little advice for you said I don't care
how smart you are any time your mouth is
open like that you look stupid I totally
remember that but I'm ah but kind of a
mouth breather as a person are you
someone who stare are you as someone who
gets caught staring exactly I I will
like focus on somebody's nose or their
arm and then before you know it I'm not
even thinking about their nose or arm
and I'm just doing this doing a church
to my sister when you stop staring
what were you staring at in church right
just somebody's nose right you zone out
a little bit early zone out and the
mouth is a gate and you look stupid from
what I understand from my good friend
Harrison so his advice was keep your
mouth shut
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please